[Music]
do you guys believe in
palm reading what does my mom say
yes what do you mean by believe like
would they tell you then you're like
yeah it's true
i palm read every night
you know how palm reading like they say
like because of the lines on your hands
it determines your destiny or whatever
it is there's a life line there's a love
line
though the left side or the right side i
don't even know i don't yes or no can i
say yes or no
yeah yes or no i would say no for
now but i'm open to the idea of it i
just haven't met anyone that that was
that accurate i believe in jesus sorry
[ __ ] you guys
what was the last time you prayed i
tried to pray i prayed for survival when
when cryptocurrency was going down he
was like oh dear god please on sunday
sunday it's awesome i got an accident i
said jesus please
on sunday got an accident like on a
bicycle
i fell oh [ __ ] you just fell on a off
your bike yeah
i yeah you got bad scrapes i did but you
can't really see it you do the mountain
biking you sound like taiko right now
you know what happened yeah this the
rocks slid
and then i flew forward and i hit my
chest
on a fence you've been getting [ __ ] up
oh right you [ __ ] you up
mercury retrograde yeah that's right so
you believe in murky retrograde just not
palm reading
i read i told you i believe i'm reading
every night
i do people falling on vice is one of
the funniest things i was hoping he
recorded it okay i feel
forward like this one and my chest hit
and then at the same time i'm like
thinking
no wonder people use chest plates
are you wearing a helmet dude yeah my
favorite is actually like
you know when you watch like the tour de
france yeah the uh
my favorite isn't the first guy that
falls once this fool falls
he it caused a domino effect and then
then after everyone falls
the guy that fell and affected him the
most finds the first
faller and beats the [ __ ] out of him
that's my favorite and you see two dudes
and tights
and they're just [ __ ] wailing they're
like [ __ ] [ __ ] the race i don't give a
[ __ ] because they can't win now
you know who fell off a bike that was
the [ __ ] funniest so you know when we
all started getting the bikes uh
abe abe started hopping on biking too
with this smooth ass palms you can't get
that [ __ ] you're talking about palm
reading dude
so this dude so he hasn't ridden a bike
in over like 15 [ __ ] years
and so i'm giving him about the bikes
that he should [ __ ]
get right he decides to get a three
grand bike 3k
out right i'm like [ __ ] you haven't
ridden a bike in years so
[ __ ] funniest thing ever so we we're
riding
at most maybe 30 seconds in right this
[ __ ] hits a crack
and he flies off his bike and you know
me
i i was actually really proud of myself
because i didn't laugh at him at that
moment
i asked if he was okay but he did the
funniest [ __ ] thing i've ever seen a
person do
this flies off his bike right i [ __ ] you
not he curls into a ball
he falls he gets up he goes there's a
crack
i'm like dog we know we saw you fall and
he starts explaining to us that there's
a crack here though
immediately he goes there's a crack
right here guys because he's so
embarrassed he goes hey there's a
cracker i just see that guys
i'm like doc what the [ __ ] just happened
he scrapes up his 3k bike in the first
30 seconds of riding it
that's why you got to buy a hundred
dollar walmart bike first exactly
do what this guy does what kind of crack
like why would he well
it's a special road bike right yeah road
bikes have very thin
tires yeah so you have to be mindful
especially when you're riding on these
crack streets in south pasadena
and so he was seeing me ride my but i
have a gravel bike so gravel bikes can
go over basically anything they have
thicker tires right so
he spent three thousand dollars on a
bike that can't go over a crack
but his bike is fast his bike is at
least i think his he got a
giant tcr so i think it was like 16
pounds so my bike's about 24 to 25. it'd
be fast if it wasn't south pasadena
i mean you could literally pick up this
bike with like your finger that's how
light it is
yeah that's cool can't you go like 40
miles per hour on those if you'd like
going i mean you can go as fast as you
want if you go downhill that's just
frightening as [ __ ] but what about this
palm reading show oh yeah yeah so this
palm reading [ __ ] so this
this [ __ ] this uh so this one
believe it
this lady in thailand she
decided to she decided to open up a
tattoo shop
to alter palm line what so you can live
longer
oh i like that [ __ ] you don't work like
that she's like you know what
[ __ ] all this [ __ ] i'm gonna change your
death smart
[ __ ] only bleeding yeah so people are
going into her shop to alter
take life into your own hands [ __ ]
exactly
that is crazy nikki you're sleeping
they're trying to get away with murder
it's like we're trying to like you know
that's not my pawn print yo this girl
kind of cute though
oh yeah she's pretty right yeah so so is
the first one with the blue shirt on the
bottom
yeah she's pretty too she's like older
pretty is she pretty she's like santa's
wife
dude i bet you they're like seven days
she looks like such as life
they're like 70 looking at that they
actually think that they can change
their destiny but
hold on a second i know there's a
lifeline so they're trying to live
longer by just drawing it all
the way all the way to their i'm going
to leave your [ __ ] skin is you mark
the whole wow
oh did you guys know that if you're not
black you're also ashy you just can't
see this of course no we can see it dude
oh i'm pretty ashy oh that looks painful
like me too we all are look at this
you see a bunch of [ __ ] flecks come
out i'm too moisturized but
[ __ ] weird flex but yeah so uh
she claims that a lot of people have
already gotten very successful
because of their altering of palm lines
so for her
for example she has a very successful
tattoo shop i'm in
change my phone lines i want it and then
this other guy that he
he was a shoe salesman after he altered
his
his money line that he just sold all the
shoes in his shop and he's mega
successful now good for them
they could have just done feng shui in
their house that that should work too
right
you know my mom used to do something
similar to this on me so like in
chinese culture when you have big ears
um it means you have a lot of luck
so my mom used to make me pull on my
ears like every night
for like five to ten minutes damn tiff
have you had a lot of luck
oh [ __ ] yeah actually my whole life is
lucky you're not getting big
no she used to get teased for it that
was her oh no earlobes like that
they're smaller now because it's like
[ __ ] you ran out of your life
you just grew you just had adult ears
when you're a kid you just grew into it
no it's about the earlobes like you know
like every single chinese buddha drawing
because they're lucky right it goes like
down here i always wonder why he has
such deformed ass ears you could just
gauge your ears maybe he was just diving
yeah
then you have a lot of luck all the kids
i know that gauge their ears all big in
high school their lobes are huge now
that's true yeah unlucky lives oh but
they have the holes
yeah that doesn't count yeah but anyway
so this is really interesting
so a lot of people in thailand have been
flocking to her
shop and a lot of people are saying that
like some people are saying that they
truly believe like their life will
change after getting these tattoos good
for them
and other people are saying like well
you know [ __ ]
i just i want to get it i believe in
buddha no they're like it's like
insurance
yeah they're like just in case it does
work i want to get it well i think like
regardless
i don't think it's gonna work but i
think the fact that they believe that
it's gonna work
and they're constantly thinking about
what it is that manifest what you focus
on grows
yes exactly you know yeah it's like
plaquemines so i think it is going to be
boss i think so too honestly the same
because uh i've been listening to this
recent book that is actually talking
about the scientific
like down to the atoms on how uh the
observer effect can
like once you're actually watching some
electrons and [ __ ] and what's the
observer effect it's when science
the way you describe it is so [ __ ]
chola i know like insane
that's because i i i don't remember the
exact terminology
when the neutrons and the electrons are
like together
so like you know is the book called
biology of belief no it's called the
breaking the habit of being yourself and
so um
in that one they're talking about how
like atoms are made of subparticles and
those sub-particles
when you actually look deep into it what
is it made of
energy belief not even made out of
matter and then when
scientists actually observed these
certain electrons and stuff and like
these
particles that depending on the observer
the those would act in different ways so
we are pretty much
we're putting out our intentions and our
energies and that we can change things
down to a molecular level
the water crystal one have you seen oh
i've seen that my mom [ __ ] loves that
one yes
it's like okay so japanese scientists i
love you
yeah and they're like one they're like i
love you you're so great i love you
i love you such good water and then the
other one they're like [ __ ] you your
piece of [ __ ] water and it turned into a
middle finger
the like the good one turned into like
snowflake crystal structures it was like
beautiful
art and then the like one they were
hating on was like blobby
atomical structures if you go to my mom
you need to send me that [ __ ] that is
fascinating it is
[ __ ] if you go to my mom's house in
her garage literally she has
2 000 dvds of that and she can't wait to
spread this [ __ ]
like really i get like we get my mom
allowance every month and this is the
kind of [ __ ] she spends money on
any type of like uh palm reading like
any type of like supernatural way to
change your life she has volumes
does it know that the internet's free no
she goes around passing this [ __ ] out to
people
oh that's nice i don't even got a dvd
player no more
how do you use a cd like i don't have
anything to put in here
your xbox i don't got an xbox that's
true if you use
do i i don't have access oh [ __ ] yeah
but yeah so like back to what you're
saying the fact that they believe that
and they're putting that in
i believe that's why their lives are
changing they don't even know it has
nothing to do with the tattoos
but maybe they needed to the reminder
yeah yeah the reminder
yeah i know it's really interesting
would you get that tattoo then
no i'll just try to like i want you to
[ __ ] put a line down my spine i don't
give a [ __ ]
make me live forever there's people that
have those tattoos too that's kind of
like jim carrey right when he first
started he wrote himself a million
dollar check he's like one day i'm gonna
have one of these dog man that [ __ ]
could work out so bad
like if you did that [ __ ] and it never
happened i would make fun of that person
for the rest of their life
the secret is you don't tell nobody man
yeah you [ __ ] loser [ __ ] that million
dollar chick
your water crystals are gonna look like
what do you have such bad luck
my block is bad like really painted at
all but here's the thing though
i like to [ __ ] up my life so i take the
bad juju from everybody thank you
you'd hang out with us more dude you're
like a [ __ ] filter piece of trash you
just contradicted yourself that me
you said that if someone else drives up
do something some good
that you make fun of them that's you're
you're throwing bad juju yeah i'm making
fun of them doesn't mean bad things are
going to happen
he's testing the fragility of that
person's goodness
if i don't make fun of people i have no
living that's what i do for a living you
nuts
[ __ ] crazy his money line goes crazy
when he makes fun of people
you see my instagram when i was making
fun of people it just started
skyrocketing this [ __ ] was exhausting
it's emotionally exhausting dude i know
i was a fan of those people are like
dude more i'm like no i want to be happy
he finds success when he gets to be
negative i know when i'm happy people
hate it
[ __ ] man really true yeah they like i
like seeing you in pain me too maybe
that's what it is
it's more entertaining seeing david in
misery i love it
when have we seen you like joyous i'm
always happy sometimes he's naked and he
does a pose and
i'm actually happy 99 of the time it's
just the one percent where i'm angry is
burst and it goes away
yeah yeah my favorite even you're angry
is funny i don't think he's ever
really negative yeah i don't know you're
never negative no there's no point
my favorite is when we had that one jk
retreat a big bear oh please let's not
talk about it hey so that's
that wraps this up david wore his socks
inside out for some reason so the
fuzzy's on the outside and it's a
hardwood floor cabin
i'm we're going downstairs and this will
he slipped
oh [ __ ] and you see him look up at the
sky like
why me and i'm like david your socks are
inside out
it's not even bad luck it's just stupid
his existence i got
paddled by that stairs so bad my [ __ ]
ass hurt dude that's just it [ __ ]
die almost every time we go somewhere my
favorite one is
what you're backing up
well that was when the [ __ ] when joe
hit him in the face with the
with the surfboard so that already had
happened like the hour before
so he fell on my surfboard and it hit
him in the face and he got bloody nose
and he's parking poof and he's like oh
can you see the forehead smudge on the
window
we were taking surf lessons and david's
like don't worry i'll record you joe and
joe's surfboard went straight into his
nose oh my god
all i remember was going no and i'm
falling and i see the surfboard
and david's standing there with the
camera like this i gotta send you
in the [ __ ] blood i gotta find that
clip the funniest part of that video is
the part i didn't upload is where
when you i get hit and then in the water
all yours is what the [ __ ]
like oh yeah look at that this whole bar
it's like
oh no turtle turtle that's
adorable and you turn the camera around
there's blood
everywhere oh there's another time where
i [ __ ] stabbed myself with the straw
at the start my god you're talking [ __ ]
to mario i remember
i got out of the water to look over and
he's
with his blood all over his [ __ ] face
we're unloading the [ __ ] car
and the bag of ice breaks and then like
it fell on the floor and then you do the
[ __ ] splits
like a cartoon character
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you